to do this companies would get a tax
credit to rehire those workers that were
laid off during the pandemic
and travelers would get a credit on all
their trade show related expenses
our first order of business of course is
crushing this virus and we are making
great progress in doing that
and as we defeat this virus we need to
quickly be able to rebound
and this bill will help us do that the
bill also includes a credit for
restaurants who renovate or increase
their service post pandemic if this
passes in washington
all of the major the measures would be
in place for several years
next on politics now protecting our
great view
one of the earliest bills to pass a
house in the legislature
keeps nevada's rural skies dark we'll
talk about it here on eight news now
welcome back parts of rural nevada have
some of those you see there
darkest skies in the country and a bill
that has been passed by the state senate
aims to keep them that way
senate bill 52 lets the state give a
dark sky designation to
places that don't have a whole lot of
artificial light or light pollution
the goal is to draw in more tourists who
want to bask in the stars
the senate passed the plan unanimously
this week and now heads over to the
state assembly
all right so now in what to watch it's
the return of school here in southern
nevada
monday marks the first day some clark
county school district students
in k through third grade we'll head back
to actual class
on campus we're going to keep an eye on
how it goes in this first week
and next week also marks a year since
our first coronavirus case here in
nevada
we're going to dig into where we are now
with the pandemic and look back at the
year of lockdowns and
wearing masks all coming up next week
we thank you very much for watching
politics now don't forget you can stay
up to date
online on all the things happening
politics here in nevada and around the
country
on dot com we'll see you back here next
saturday take care
you